gumbo is in my heart it's in my soul i
grew up in new orleans louisiana and in
my family gumbo season starts around
thanksgiving time it is served for every
major holiday leading all the way up to
mardi gras and sometimes a little bit
afterwards what makes gumbo extra
special to me is its diverse roots the
dish is over 300 years old and has
several cultural influences from all
over from the caribbean france germany
and native americans but many believe
its origins are in the west african
cuisine the word gumbo actually derives
from the word for okra in some west
african languages and its use of rice
also indicates its ties directly to
africa rice was brought over during the
transatlantic slave trade and became a
highly cultivated crop in america
there's no right or wrong way to make
gumbo well there definitely is a wrong
way to make gumbo but today the version
we're making is going to have you
falling in love with gumbo done the
right way so let's jump into the kitchen
to make some gumbo baby
so today we're making seafood fillet
gumbo and it all starts with a homemade
stock now you can buy chicken seafood
vegetable or even beef stock but people
will look at you a little funny if you
put beef stock in your gumbo but hey
we're not here to judge
however most families make their own
stock at home using the vegetable scraps
and the seafood scraps to make it from
scratch we start with heating up some
oil in a heavy bottom five quart pot
over medium heat once it's hot we'll add
three blue crabs you can find bukur
these crabs in the gulf of mexico
there's definitely something magical
going on in those murky waters that make
them taste amazing so don't use
dungeness or stone crabs trust me it
won't taste the same let these guys cook
until their shells turn a bright orange
then we'll add shrimp shells with their
heads these will make for a far more
superior stock we'll cook these until
the shells turn pink now it's time to
smash the shells it's similar to mashing
potatoes doing this is going to help
release all those extra juices so really
get in there and take out your daily
frustration and finally we'll add some
vegetable scraps
[Music]
and some seasoning cover this all with
water and bring it to a slight boil
then bring it down to a simmer for at
least 30 to 35 minutes now we'll strain
it and set it to the side you see making
your own homemade stock isn't that hard
and i know you're smelling the
difference next we'll move on to our own
seasoning we're going to make our own
creole cajun blend and if you ever get a
blend from someone else make sure that
they're from southern louisiana i'm
talking new orleans appaloosas lafayette
baton rouge or the surrounding areas
outsiders put weird stuff like chili
powder and cumin in it that's a big
no-no baby we don't do that around here
our blend is a combination of kosher
salt white pepper black pepper cayenne
paprika garlic powder onion powder dry
thyme and oregano we'll whisk all of
these together in a bowl man it is
starting to smell like home
now we're ready to start cooking this
gumbo now grab a large pot place it over
medium high heat and add in some canola
oil cook this until it reaches a smoke
point you're looking for a faint white
smoke anything thicker is going to burn
our root the smoke is so faint the
camera couldn't even capture it so pay
real close attention this next step can
be controversial we're going to add in
some okra not all families add okra to
the affiliate gumbo but some people
believe a gumball without okra just
isn't gumbo we're team okra over here
friday's for a couple of minutes until
they turn the army green this will
remove all the slime you don't need to
eat slimy okra after a few minutes
remove them from the pot and drain them
on a paper towel
let's move on to the room this is my
favorite part right here besides eating
a roux is a mixture of flour and fat
that's used as a thickener in all sorts
of recipes from fancy mac and cheese to
soups and stews rules can be a variety
of shades from blind to dark brown gumbo
requires a dark brown roux so we're
using the oil for this typically it
takes about 30 to 45 minutes to get that
kind of root but i'm gonna teach you a
technique to get that dark brown roux in
five minutes yeah i said five minutes
we'll turn up our heat and get it back
to that perfect smoke point remember
we're looking for a faint white smoke
heating the oil before adding the flour
will fry the flour quickly giving it
that classic nutty flavor whisk the
flour until it turns a dark cocoa brown
if the rule is browning too fast remove
the pot off the heat while continuously
stirring and reduce your heat to medium
low
look you didn't believe me huh a
beautiful perfect cocoa brown root in
five minutes so next we'll add onion
bell pepper
and celery this vegetable trio is known
as the holy trinity this is the backbone
of creole cajun cooking two tablespoons
of our seasoning blend we're gonna stir
this for two to three minutes and then
add some garlic bay leaves and the rest
of our seasoning blend you want to add
your seasoning in layers to add depth of
flavor to your gumbo turn up the heat to
medium high and gradually add the
seafood stock if you don't have a whisk
stirring in different directions will
break up any clumps we want a nice
smooth gumbo don't nobody have time for
no lumpy gumbo then it's time to add our
okra smoked sausage crabs
thyme and worcestershire sauce now
there's a variety of proteins you can
add to your gumbo personally we love the
smoked sausage crab and shrimp combo
typically you don't add chicken to your
seafood gumbo but hey do what makes you
feel great if you don't like seafood or
have an allergy you can simply go with a
chicken and sausage gumbo which is also
known as gumbo yaya right now let's
bring our mixture to a boil and then
reduce the heat to a low simmer for one
hour uncovered your house is about to
smell like a new orleans grandmother's
house skim off any foam residue that
rises to the top this is just the flour
cooking out nothing weird after about an
hour your gumbo should have thickened
and reduced bile quarter we are in the
home stretch now but before we get to
that last step we're going to take a
quick taste just to make sure it's
seasoned properly
so delicious then we'll add our shrimp
and remove our pot from the heat the
gumbo is going to be so hot that the
shrimp will cook in 10 minutes
now it's time to eat baby call your
family over and get a bowl we love to
serve our gumbo over rice some people
like more rice than gumbo others like
a5050 i'm a more gumbo than rice guy
do what you love
garnish with parsley green onions and
finish it off with some filet powder
filet powder is ground sassafras leaves
this is the native american part of the
dish it's going to add that final
distinct layer of flavor that can only
be found in filet let me tell you now
this is a bowl full of love flavor
family heritage memories and everything
else that's good and lovely in the world
i hope you love sharing a piece of my
family history with your own family
check out the recipe on tasted.com and
let us know if you make this delicious
seafood feeling gumbo baby
oh yes
[Music]